Німецька компанія Biontech та американський фармацевтичний гігант Pfizer заявили
про успішні клінічні випробування вакцини від короновірусу. За їхнім твердженням, медикамент має 90-відсоткову дієвість,
тобто 90 відсотків прищеплених осіб отримують захист від Covid-19.
Це дуже висока дієвість, оцінюють незалежні науковці.
Успіхом вважалися б навіть 50 відсотків - планка, яку ставить для ковід-вакцин Служба лікарських засобів США.
Для порівняння: ефективність щеплень від грипу, наприклад, минулої зими в Німеччині, була на рівні 62 відсотків.
Вакцину розробили у лабораторії Biontech в німецькому Майнці у січні,
коли мало хто в Європі чув про коронавірус, його тоді називали китайським.
Ще у березні американський концерн Pfizer підписав контракт з німцями
обсягом до 750 мільйонів доларів на спільну розробку вакцини.
І вже у травні почалися її перші перевірки державними відомствами в США
після успішних перших випробувань у Німеччині у квітні цього року.
Свій проєкт генні технологи назвали light speed - "швидкість світла".
Тому що в минулому і за традиційною технологією розробка вакцин тривала подекуди десять років.
Німецько-американський тандем хоче вже наступного тижня подати заявку до Служби лікарських засобів США.
Компанії розраховують на термінову процедуру видачі дозволу на виробництво, зважаючи на те, які надії покладені на медпрепарат.
Попередня ціна на щеплення двома дозами препарату становитиме до 39 доларів. Так записано в угоді про поставки до США.
В європейських країнах не буде дешевше, зазначає виробник.
Pfizer та Biontech прогнозують, що ще цього року буде виготовлено до 50 мільйонів доз вакцини від коронавірусу по всьому світі.
Цього було б достатньо для щеплення 25 мільйонів осіб. Приціл на 2021 рік - до 1 мільярда 300 мільйонів доз.
Вакцина може мати різні властивості. У випадку з препаратом "біонтек", вона блокує потрапляння вірусу в організм.
Інші функції, наприклад, зупиняти поширення вірусу або захищати від важкого перебігу інфекцій - поки дослідженнями не доведено.
Керівник Biontech Уґур ШахІн сподівається, що завдяки щепленню їхньою вакциною вдасться досягнути імунітету тривалістю один рік.
Але напевно можна сказати поки лише про 28 днів, які тримався імунітет після щеплення на даному етапі дослідження.
Розподіл вакцини - завдання не з легких. Навіть для прогресивної Німеччини.
Якщо вакцина від грипу перевозиться дещо охолодженою,
то препарат від коронавірусу на базі РНК вимагає температури зберігання близько мінус 70-ти градусів за Цельсієм.
Тож, на думку експертів, для доставки має бути розроблена ціла система заходів.
Навіть за наявності необхідної кількості доз, кажуть фахівці, аби перевезти та прищепити усіх мешканців країни,
може знадобитися багато місяців, якщо не років. А коли почнеться щеплення - поки неясно.
Під час розподілу в ФРН першими хочуть забезпечити групи ризику, медиків, а вже в другу чергу решту громадян.
Щеплення, як і у випадку з грипом, потрібно буде робити щороку через мутацію вірусу, кажуть експерти.
У Росії препарат "Спутник V" влада дозволила ще до початку третього, вирішального етапу досліджень, який триває нині.
У Німеччині такий підхід назвали вкрай ризикованим.
Розробка біонтеківської вакцини відбувалась у три етапи. На першому етапі препарат отримали кілька десятків здорових людей,
аби перевірити його переносимість організмом. На другому перевірили реакцію імунної системи,
прищепили кілька сотень осіб, в тому числі інфікованих коронавірусом.
На третьому досліджувалась, власне, дієвість та побічні дії вакцини, за участі понад 40 тисяч людей.
Цей етап стартував ще у липні, тоді як у російського "Супутника V" - лише у вересні.
Окрім Biontech, експерти уважно стежать за розробками інших компаній.
Загалом, за оцінками ВООЗ, на стадії клінічних досліджень перебувають 47 різних проєктів.
Американська компанія "Модерна", яка отримала від уряду Сполучених Штатів підтримку в майже один мільярд доларів,
обіцяє представити результати третьої стадії досліджень у листопаді.
Китай, як і Росія, видав власним компаніям "Сіновак" та "Сінофарм" дозволи на використання вакцини,
не чекаючи завершення її досліджень, з огляду на термінову потребу в щепленні.